NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
[inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY EGGMAN.
FLORA FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
ISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES CARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES REVISE
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
STEINORTH STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND OUR
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S A
VOCATION.
WILL TO BE OFFERED BY OUR
REVELING CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA REVENUES.
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IN MANY WAYS OUR LIVES ARE
DEFINED AND GIVEN MEANING BY OUR
COMMITMENTS.
PROMISES MADE OATHS TAKEN.
AND BLOUSE MADE AND KEPT.
MY WIFE PATTY AND I HAVE LONG
BEEN INVOLVED IN SCOUTING.
WE WATCHED YOUNG CUB SCOUTS AND
DAISIES GIRL SCOUTS BEGIN TO
LEARN WHO THEY ARE IN TAKINGYOU
KNOW.
AND MAKING A PROMISE.
THEIR SCOUT OATH AND PROMISES
BEGIN WITH THE PHRASES.
ON MY HONOR.
AND I WILL DO MY BEST.
AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE THEY BEGIN
TO CONSIDER WHO AM I AND WHAT IS
MY HONOR.
THESE ARE WONDERFUL QUESTIONS
FOR TO KNOW OURSELVES WILL BE A
LIFETIME GOAL.
INSIGHTFUL TEACHER DR NOBLE
HUNNID THAT WOULD OFTEN SAY.
IN LIFE THERE'S ONLY ONE PERSON
WE NEED TO MEET AND KNOW.
THAT PERSON IS OURSELVES.
ONLY IN KNOWING WHO WE ARE.
CAN WE BEGIN TO CONSIDER WHAT IS
MY HONOR.
WHAT IS WHAT IS IT WITHIN ME
THAT IS HONORABLE TRUSTWORTHY
AND RELIABLE?
THE SECOND PHRASE I WILL DO MY
BEST.
MAY BE OUR GREATEST LIFETIME
CHALLENGE.
IN LIVING OUR LIVES WE CAN WISH
FOR NO MORE.
THAN TO BE ABLE TO SAY I'M DOING
MY VERY BEST.
AND IF WE CAN LIVE OUR LIVES
TRULY DOING THE BEST WE CAN.
BEING THE BEST HUMAN BEINGS WE
CAN BE.
WE CANNOT HELP BUT IN TIME LOOK
BACK ON OUR LIVES WITH NO
REGRETS.
ON MY HONOR AND I WILL DO MY
BEST.
THE SIMPLE PHRASES WILL DEFINE
AND GIVE MEANING TO OUR LIVES.
IN THE PROMISES WE MAKE.
THE OAKS WE TAKE AND ABOUT US WE
MAKE AND KEEP.
NUMBER ONE THE THEM.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND I INVITE OUR
GUESTS AND MEMBERS TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR TODAY SLOT FLAG
SALUTE.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED TODAY BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ITS ELEMENT AND NINETY
M. ON BILL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHEAPER DEDUCTIBLES
MATTER CALDERON MOVES TO MISTER
DALLI SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL
SANTIAGO.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
[inaudible]
DOCTORS [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLYMAN.
WEBER TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT
AND TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB NINETY SIX SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY FROM ENROLLMENT AND
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW COMMITTEES TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS. TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
SET A S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY ONE MY
COUNTY AND S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN STERN PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE PARK.
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE AS THE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE MCGUIRE PENDING REFERRAL
FROM HUMAN.
SERVICES COMMITTEE AS WE NINETY
FOUR SKINNER PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE COUNT ABILITY IN
MINISTRY REVIEW COMMITTEE AND S.
B. TEN FORTY FIVE WIENER PENDING
RECEIPT FROM HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR SPECIAL HEARING ON THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH.
ALSO TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO SET S. B. A TWENTY
JACKSON FOR THEIR TUESDAY JUNE
TWENTY SIX HEARING.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO REFER RE
REFER.
S. B. THIRTY FIFTY FIVE HELP
FROM THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS THERE IS A REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE RULES ROOM.
REPUBLICANS THERE IS A
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE RULES
ROOM
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
CORRECTION ON ABSENCES MISTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO
IS PRESENT TODAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL ATTENTION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
INTRODUCING HIS GAS FROM MISTER
MULLINS DESK.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE ERIK
ESTRADA.
A DISTINGUISHED CALIFORNIA ACTOR.
TELEVISION HOST AN ACTIVIST FOR
HUMANITARIAN CAUSES WHO BROUGHT
CREDIT AND DISTINCTION. TO
HIMSELF.
AND TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH HIS CAREER AND CIVIC
ACHIEVEMENT ACHIEVEMENTS AND
THROUGH HIS STRONG AND GENEROUS
CONNECTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
WHY WHILE WE MAY ALL REMEMBER
ERICA'S PUNCH?
FROM THE TELEVISION DRAMA CHIPS.
ERIC'S REAL LIFE DEDICATION TO
PUBLIC SAFETY IS WHAT WE ARE
HERE TO HONOR TODAY.
ERIC IS AN ACTIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE CHP ELEVEN NINETY NINE
FOUNDATION.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
BENEFITS AND SCHOLARSHIPS TO SEE
HP FAMILY MEMBERS.
AS WELL AS FUNERAL EXPENSES FOR
FALLEN OFFICERS.
HE VOLUNTEERS HIS TIME BY
SPEAKING EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN SUPPORT OF ASSOCIATION
IN ORDER TO HELP THE FOUNDATION.
THIS FOUNDATION HAS DISTRIBUTED
MORE THAN THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF ASSISTANCE. TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY BENEFITS TO
SEE HP EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN A TIME OF CRISIS.
ERIC IS ALSO A LOYAL AND
COMMITTED SUPPORTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN WIDOWS AND
ORPHANS TRUST FUND.
WHICH IS DEDICATED TO ASSISTING
FAMILIES OF FALLEN CHP OFFICERS
IN THE EVENT THEY DIE.
REGARDLESS OF BECAUSE AS THE
BENEFIT OF BEING.
OF BEING HIGHER FOR THOSE KILLED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
PROVIDING IMMEDIATE ACTION
DISBURSING THE BENEFIT AS SOON.
AS NOTIFICATION OF THE DEATH OF
AN OFFICER'S ME.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT THE
ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION DEREK WHICH
READS IN PART.
WERE IS CITIZENS SERVICE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN AN INTERCULTURAL OF
THE FOUNDATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
WHICH DEPENDS ON OUTSTANDING
CITIZENS STEPPING FORWARD TO
SERVE THE NEEDS OF OTHERS.
AND STRENGTHEN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEIR PASTRANA HAS EMBRACED
A ROLL OF SERVICE AS SURELY AS
THE CHP OFFICER HE ONCE PLAYED
[inaudible]
THEREFORE.
BE IT RESOLVED IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY.
RECOGNIZES AND THANKS ERICA
ESTRADA FOR A LIFETIME OF
ACHIEVEMENT ACHIEVEMENT AND
MERITORIOUS SERVICE [inaudible]
TO HUMANITY.
THANK YOU ERIC.
FREE SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING ERIK
ESTRADA ARE ASSEMBLY BASS.
TODAY THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH US HERE
TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA FOR HER GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M HONORED
TO WELCOME THE FIFTY YEAH I'M
LEON LEGISLATORS FROM THE
DISTRICT WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
STUDENTS AT A HIGH SCHOOL
JUNIORS AND SENIORS THAT HAVE
BEEN.
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
SINCE DECEMBER WHERE THEY'VE
BEEN LEARNING ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THEIR OWN BILL.
AND LATER TODAY WE'LL BE HAVING
THEIR OWN LOT COMMITTEE SESSIONS
IN A MONTH FLOOR SESSION.
PLEASE HELP ME IN WELCOMING THE
YOUNG LEGISLATORS FROM THE
FIFTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHO
ARE UP IN THE GALLERY TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I MCCARTY.
IS RECOGNIZED FOR HIS GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK THANK YOU AYE MADAM
SPEAKER I HAVE SOME GUEST UP IN
THE GALLERY LIKE TO INTRODUCE WE
HAVE CUT SCOUT.
FIFTY AND GIRL SCOUT TROOP. FIVE
SIX NINE THERE THEY ARE THEY'RE
HERE TODAY LEARN ABOUT OUR STATE
CAPITOL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS.
THEY'RE FROM --
DOWN HERE IN THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO AREA IN THE POCKET
AREA MY AREA MISTER COOPER'S
DISTRICTS BOTHERS CHAPERONE IS
JENNIFER BALDWIN.
AND CHRISTY MARIO GO AND WE WANT
TO WELCOME THEM TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL OF NOTES THIS WAS THE
TROOP THAT ARE REVEREND --
OUR ART OUR GUEST --
REVERIE PATTY ORGANIZED OVER
THIRTY FORTY YEARS AGO SO COMING
BACK HOME THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER FOR HER GUESTS AND GOOD
MORNING --
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
VERY PROUD HAD --
TO INTRODUCE MY GUEST TODAY YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET
MEMBERS FROM SAN DIEGO TO COME
UP BECAUSE OF THE DISTANCE OF
THE TRAVEL.
SOME OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT
SAN DIEGO IS REALLY A A CITY
THAT DEALS WITH COMMUNITY.
AND THEIR NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
COUNCILS THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO WE
ALL IDENTIFY WITH OUR COUNCIL
SOMETIMES MORE THAN WITH OUR
CITY.
AND WE HAVE SOME EXTREMELY
ACTIVE COUNCILS AND ONE OF THEM
IS HERE TODAY.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT THE
BROADWAY FIGHTS COUNCIL THIS
GROUP NOT ONLY TRAVELS AND HELPS
WITH THAT KIND OF ACTIVITIES
THAT THEIR THEIR MEMBERS NEED
AND AND GROW UP WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT HAS.
REALLY GOT INVOLVED IN SOLAR
ENERGY SO COMMUNITY THEY MAKE
SURE ALL THE MEMBERS HAVE SOLAR
ON THEIR HOMES THEY'VE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THAT THEY ALSO SEND
THEIR CHILDREN. TO VARIOUS
CONFERENCES AND SUPPORT THOSE
KIDS SO WHEN YOU GO TO THEIR
MEETINGS YOU HEAR WHAT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE ABANDONED THEY REPORT
BACK.
THEY DO ESSAY CONTEST THEY DO
YOU NAME IT THEY ARE COMMUNITY
THEY ARE AYE FAMILY AND IT'S
REALLY GOOD TO HAPPEN YOU
THEY'RE VERY ACTIVE SAN DIEGO.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY AUTHORED A BILL
ON THIS FLOOR DEALING WITH SOLAR
ENERGY THAT WE BASICALLY TOOK
AND GOT PASSED AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR SO THEY'RE VERY BOB
ROBBIE ROBINSON IS THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS WIFE LEAVE HIM.
AND I'M SO PLEASED TO HAVE
BROUGHT WAY HIKES HERE THEIR HIM
UP TO THE VISITING THE CAPITAL
THEY PUT OUT WORK THAT GOING TO
SAN FRANCISCO NAPA VALLEY.
AND A HOST OF OTHER PLACE JUST
TO ENRICH THEMSELVES SO WANT TO
TO WELCOME BROADWAY HIKES HERE
TO THE FLOOR AND IN THE GALLERY
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
OUT OF BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE MOVING TO SECOND READING
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY
WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN A SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE ET WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN THIRTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS WEALTHY FOR THE
MOMENT. TO ALSO BE FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S FIVE CITIES HAVE AT
THE MOMENT TWELVE SEVENTY
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN FIFTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN NO ONE WITH.
ELEVEN MOMENTS THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN TWENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN TWENTY BY WITH
AMENDMENTS AND FIVE FIVE ONE AT
THE MOMENT.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A ONE OTHER VERY
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US TODAY I'M
GONNA MOVE.
TO DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR HIS GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
SORRY TO SPECIAL GAS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE MY
DAUGHTER'S TO THIS FLOOR AGAIN
SO IF.
ASSEMBLY TO PLEASE HELP ME TO
WELCOME AVIANO JUNE ARAMBULA
SCARLETT ROSE ARAMBULA.
THEY APPEAR TO BE BUSY WRITING
BILLS.
SOME MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUSCONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SUCCEED TO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO HEAR S. B.. TWELVE
SIX TWO NEWMAN ON MONDAY JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH.
SOME ERROR WALDRON IT WE OPPOSE
THAT MOTION AND ASK FOR ROLL
CALL.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON.
I AM MISTER BONTA SECONDS AND
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED TO
WAIVE THE FILE NOTICE
METACARPALS OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE E. BE [inaudible]
EIGHT OH SEVEN METAPHORICALLY
SERENE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH SEVEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME.
SOME MEMBER CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZE
SUBHUMAN I'M SPEAKER SAM MEMBERS --
AB EIGHT ZERO SEVEN IS PACKED
FULL CONCURRENCE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENT.
THIS BILL CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO STAY ON DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME YOU'RE WRONG.
DESCENDED THE MA'AM AND AS IS TO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STAYS IN
BETWEEN COLOR FUNNIER AND MY
CIRCLE.
FLORIDA OF THE STATE OF PLOT
FLORIDA JUST RECENTLY PASSED A
BILL TO PUT THE STATE ON
DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME YOUR ROW.
AND THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN BOTH HOUSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I BO.
THANK YOU SEEING IN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEAS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
I DON'T THINK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NO FOR THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE A BUSINESS ON THE
FLOOR MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWENTY
TWO A. B. ELEVEN NINETY TWO
MADAME QUICKLY STREET.
AT SOME LEVEL OF A NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY OR
RECOGNIZE.
THINK ABOUT OF SPEAKER AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWOS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL AS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO REMOVE INSURGENCY
CLAUSEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NETWORK
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO TWO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY SEVEN MADAM
QUICKLY STREET.
AT SOME LITTLE TWENTY TO THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
CORPORATIONS.
SOME MEMORY CHARM THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY SEVEN WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO MAKE
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES THIS ONE
OF THE BURDEN FOR CALIFORNIANS
* TRAVELING ACROSS STATE
LINES TO ACCESS BOOKS AND
RECORDS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM COURT PLEASEOPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
VOTE.
MADAM QUICKIE MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN MAY AND IN MEMBERS --
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY THREE IS
A COMMITTEE BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE COUNTY FROM
CHARGING FEES FOR MEDI CAL
SPECIALTY MENTAL SERVE HEALTH
SERVICES TO MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES.
WHO DO NOT HAVE A SHARE OF COST
AND MEDICARE BENEFICIARY THIS
YEAR'S WHO HAVE MET THEIR SHARE
COSTS?
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT BE CONSTRUED TO
WAVE A COUNTY'S RESPONSIBILITY.
AT TO SCREEN FOR ELIGIBILITY FOR
MEDICAID OUT ANY OTHER INSURANCE
PORTABILITY PROGRAM FOR COUNTY
HEALTH PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND AND VOTING IN.
CURRENT CONCUR THANK YOU SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
NOT A PICKY MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY FIVE ACR
ONE SEVENTY TWO MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY SOME THE
NUMBER LOW AND OTHERS FELT THE
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL AND
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR.
ONE SEVENTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKING IN THE SENATE TO ADDRESS.
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
CONCERNS I AM HOPEFUL THAT MY
FELLOW REPUBLICAN CALLED CAN NOW
SUPPORT THIS ARE AT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAME CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY NINE THREE
THIRTY ONE ARE CONTINUED MOVING
TO ITEM THIRTY TWO SP TO NINETY
EIGHT MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
HOPE
.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SIMPLE TO NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI AND ACTING
THIS ELECTIONS.
SOME MEMBER WEBER.
YES MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS HIGH
RISE TO ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS TO
SP TO NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI.
THESE AMENDMENTS NARAL THE BILL
BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
PROTECTION AVAILABLE TO COULD
CONSUMERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND FOR THE
BILL TO GO OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
HER EYES. TO SENATE BILL.
TO NINETY EIGHT SEEING NONE OF
THE RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENTS.
SIMPLE TO NINETY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE NUMBER
WEBER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE BILL WAS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
ITEM THIRTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY FOUR ACR
TO THIRTY NINE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
AS I'M THE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS WILL TELL
RELATIVE TO ALZHEIMER'S IMPAIR
BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH AND THE
LONGEST DAY.
pTHANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
HONORED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO THIRTY
NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES JUNE.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS ALZHEIMER'S
AND BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH IN
JUNE TWENTY FIRST AS THE LONGEST
DAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENT MISTER
CALDERON FOR WHAT REASON DO RISE
YET MEN SPEAKER IS EXTREMELY
LOUD ON THE FLOOR I ASK THE
MEMBERS IF THERE CONVERSATIONS
TO A MINIMUM TO TAKE THEIR SEATS
TO GET THE FULL ATTENTION.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAJOR YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL ATTENTION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU CALIFORNIA HAS SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE NATION AND THE
STATE POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
GROW BY 29% IN THE NEXT DAY
DECADE.
REACHING EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THESE NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO RISE YEAR AFTER YEAR
FAMILY FRIENDS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS DISEASE THE COST IT INCURS
AND IT'S LONG LASTING A FAX.
I'M PROUD THAT MY COUNTY SAN
DIEGO TOOK CONCRETE STEPS A FEW
YEARS AGO TO BEGIN ADDRESSING
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
BUT THIS IS MORE THAN A LOCAL
CONCERNS.
IT'S STATEWIDE NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL.
THIS RESOLUTION RAISES AWARENESS
BUT WE ALSO NEED ACTION MANY OF
US IN THIS CHAMBER OF INTRODUCED
BILLS THIS SESSION TO ACCELERATE
RESEARCH.
ENHANCE CARE AND SUPPORT
IMPROVED TREATMENT.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO CORDOVA
FOR CONTINUALLY BRINGING
AWARENESS TO THIS DISEASE AND
RELATED COGNITIVE DISORDERS.
AFFORD WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU
IN THE MONTHS. TO BRING
SOLUTIONS TO FAMILIES SUFFERING
FROM ALZHEIMER'S AND RELATED
DEMENTIAS.
AND OUT MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD
LIKE THE FIRST ROLL CALL TO BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES ON THIS DAY I'M
ALWAYS --
HONORED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS SUBJECT MATTER.
IT IS ALWAYS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME TO SHARE --
AND INTONE THIS FOR THE NAME OF
MY MOM DOORS LEAK COOLEY.
WHO PASSED AWAY FROM ALZHEIMER'S
ELEVEN YEARS AGO THIS MONTH
[inaudible]
AND A STORY THAT HAS THAT ALWAYS
TAKE AWAY IS DESPITE THE RAVAGES
OF THIS DISEASE.
SHE WAS IN A CARE FACILITY
GETTING TREMENDOUS CARE FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
I WOULD VISIT MY MOM SHE WOULD
NOT RECOGNIZE ME --
AND THAT SHE WOULD SIT WITH
THEIR COMPANIONS THE PEOPLE THAT
SHE SPENT TIME WITH THEM JUST.
CHATAWAY IN WAYS THAT I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONVERSATION BUT
CLEARLY WAS BEATING.
A NEED SHE JUST GOT SUCH GREAT
CARE [inaudible]
ARE.
THEN IN THE LAST MONTH OF HER
LIFE SHE HAD A FULL SHOES IN.
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY AND I
VISITED HER.
ME BEING THE BABY OF THE FAMILY
THE ONE THAT SHE WOULD ALWAYS
GIVE ME A SMOOCH WHEN I CAME
HOME FROM COLLEGE.
AND I TALK TO MY MOM AND I
LEANED OVER HER AND HEAD ON THE
PILLOW.
AND HER HEAD JUST CAME OFF THE
PILLOW TO SMOOCH ME.
WHICH TOLD ME THAT DESPITE THE
RAVAGES OF THIS DISEASE.
SO DEEP END THE HORROR OF
ALZHEIMER'S.
A DOOR SLEEP COOLEY WAS STILL
THERE.
PERSONAGE WAS STILL THERE
HOWEVER DEFACED BY THIS DISEASE.
AND THEREFORE THIS ENTERPRISE OF
RESEARCH IS SUPPORTING RESEARCH.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO HOW TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE IN DURING THIS
THE FAMILIES.
OF TWO RESPITE CARE AND OTHER
THINGS.
A WE WE CANNOT THINK THAT THESE
DISEASES ARE SO BAD THAT THE
PERSONAL.
PERSON THAT THE CHORUS SOMEHOW
LOST.
ON SO I JUST A GREAT HONOR TO
RISE AND SUPPORT AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE.
AUSTRALIA I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
HERE IN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
MISTER.
MY COLLEAGUE OF SACRAMENTO'S --
AT EAST LAWN CEMETERY THERE'S
ACTION ALZHEIMER'S MEMORIAL WALL.
BEAUTIFUL SPOT BUT I STOPPED AT
EARLIER THIS WEEK --
TO REMEMBER THOSE WHO WHO HAVE
SUFFERED AND DIED OF THIS DREAD
DISEASE.
I ORIGINALLY VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TO THIRTY NINE AS
OF A FAMILY MORE MY FATHER
SUFFERS FROM ALZHEIMER'S FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS.
I SEE THAT AFFECTS THE DOES ON
PATIENTS AND FAMILIES AND THE AS
I LOOK AT HIM AND AND WHAT WE GO
THROUGH AS A FAMILY.
THE WE MUST ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
LOOK FOR FOR A CURE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S BUT THE MEAN TIME
THAT WE ALWAYS BE AWARE.
OF WHAT FAMILIES GO THROUGH AND
PATIENTS AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP SUPPORT THEM ALONG THE WAY.
SO ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWO THIRTY NINE THANK THE MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRING AFFORD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SUMMER I'VE YORKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AND
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- I
WANT -- TO
RISE TO TALK ABOUT A REALLY GOOD
IT IS BACK IN WASHINGTON DC WHO
HAS HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S.
AND SHE IS BACK THERE PROMOTING
IN TALKING ABOUT PREVENTION AND
WHAT WE CAN DO AND THERE ARE
SOME GREAT THINGS THAT THEY'RE
FINDING WITH SCIENCE --
I'M SO PROUD OF MY FRIEND PAM
SHE HAS TAKEN MANY TRIPS TO
TRAIN AND TEACH ALL OF US AND
EDUCATE US ABOUT.
THE EARLY SIGNS OF ALZHEIMER'S.
AND THEN ON THE OTHER SIDE WANT
TO SAY --
GOD REST MY MOURN MY MY BEST
FRIENDS FROM MY KINDERGARTEN
DIED EARLY ONSET ALZHEIMER'S.
SO THIS AFFECTS ALL ALL PEOPLE
SO I WANT TO JUST CONCURRENT ALL
OF US TO A SUPPORT THIS TODAY
AND THANK YOU MIGHT VERY MUCH
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE A IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRING IT FORWARD.
NAM IN THE PROCESS OF READING A
BOOK CALLED BEFORE I FORGET IT'S
BY IT'S WRITTEN ABOUT BE SMITH
THOUGH WELL KNOWN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN WHO WAS A THE
BLACK MARTHA STEWART IN ESSENCE.
AND HER BATTLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S
AND TO READ THAT BOOK AND TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE OVER
FAMILY HER HUSBAND AND HER
COMMUNITY IS JUST AMAZING.
IT'S ALSO BECAME AWARE OF THE
FACT OF THE DATA THAT THE GROUP
THAT'S MOST AFFECTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S AS AFRICAN AMERICANS.
IT HAS THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE WHO HAVE ALZHEIMER'S
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WOULD NOT
THE LARGEST POPULATION IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAVE THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF ALZHEIMER'S.
GREATER NUMBERS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS WILL GET ALZHEIMER'S
TWO AND THREE TIMES MORE THAN
THE NORMAL POPULATION THE NEED
FOR RESEARCH IS CLEARLY APPARENT
IT'S BEEN THERE FOR YEARS WE'VE
NOT DONE MUCH BECAUSE OFTEN
PEOPLE DIDN'T LIVE AS LONG.
AND SO WE JUST KIND OF ROLLED
OFF OUR GRANDPARENTS AND OTHERS
AS BEING FORGETFUL NOW WE SEE
THIS DEEP DISEASES THEIR IN
HOUSE RAVAGING OUR COMMUNITIES.
CONSUMING SO MANY RESOURCES IN
HIM AND HAPPENED SO MANY LIVES
SO I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE BASICALLY ACCEPT THIS
RESOLUTION ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND
THEN ENCOURAGED OUR GOVERNMENT
AND OUR STATE TO TALK ABOUT
RESEARCH.
AND WHAT THESE TO HAPPEN FOR THE
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES SO I THINK
MOST ARE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BASICALLY BRINGING
THIS FORWARD REMINDING US OF HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS AND THAT WE ALL
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BECAUSE
IT AFFECTS ALL OF OUR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES AFTER THEIR GREAT
COMMENTS ON IN OUR HOUSE THE
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
BRUCE.
THIS VOTE IS FOR A CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEDI PERKY MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY THREE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED RETURNING NOW TO MR
MAIENSCHEIN FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN HONOR OF ALZHEIMER'S
AND BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH AND
TODAY BEING RECOGNIZED AS THE
LONGEST DAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ADVOCATES WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WERE UP IN THE
GALLERY INCLUDING MEMBERS OF
FROM THE SAN DIEGO ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUOUS
EFFORTS IN FINDING A CURE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND I'D ASK
MY COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE EXTEND A
WARM WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY
FIVE AC AYE ACR.
TO FORTY MADAM QUICKLY THREE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY BY SOMETHING KALRA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE.
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALL DAY OF
YOGA THANK YOU SO MEMBER KALRA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THE MENACE SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ACR TO FORTY RECOGNIZE TODAY IS
INTERNATIONAL DAY OF YOGA IN
CALIFORNIA.
INTERNATIONAL DAY OF YOGA
DECLARED BY THE UNITED NATIONS
AS A WAY TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOGA'S
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON THE WORLD.
ALSO RECOGNIZES YOGA AS AN
INVALUABLE GIFT FROM INDIA
ROOTED IN HINDU AND BATHING
TRADITIONS.
TODAY YOU GUYS PRACTICE AND HAS
INSPIRED MILLIONS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS CULTURES TRADITIONS
RELIGIONS AND NATIONALITIES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
YOGA CAN BE AN OPPORTUNITY
DISCOVER SENSE OF UNITY AND
CONNECTION WITH ONESELF AND OUR
SURROUNDINGS.
IN THIS SPIRIT OF INTERNATIONAL
DAY OF YOGA I'D LIKE TO SHARE.
A COUPLE OF INSPIRING CLOSE BY
SHE SHE REALLY SHOCKER
HUMANITARIAN AND RENOWNED.
YOGA PRACTITIONER.
YOGA IS A STUDY OF LIFE STUDY OF
YOUR BODY WRATH MIND INTELLECT
MEMORY AND EGO.
STUDY OF YOUR INNER FACULTIES.
PEACE IS OUR VERY NATURE AND
YOGA LEADS YOU TO INNER PEACE.
ACR TO FORTY RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT ALL THESE IMPORTANT
BENEFITS OF YOGA AND ALSO
REMINDS US THAT WE ALL SHARE THE
COMMON GOAL.
OF UPLIFTING ONE ANOTHER AND THE
HUMAN EXPERIENCE REGARDLESS OF
WHERE WE COME FROM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER KALRA WOULD YOU
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS MISTER COLOR IS
REQUESTING THAT THIS RULE BE
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS BENEFIT
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
ON THE DAY OF YOGA.
AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY SIX HR ONE
TWELVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE TWELVE BY
SOME THE MEMBER DAVID CHIU
RELATIVE TO IMMIGRANT HERITAGE
MONTH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT HR ONE TWELVE
WHICH RECOGNIZES JUNE. TWO OF
THIS MONTH AS IMMIGRANT HERITAGE
MONTH.
WE'LL KNOW THAT WHO WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY AND AS A STATE IS
BECAUSE OF OUR IMMIGRANTS THAT
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA WAS
BUILT BY IMMIGRANTS THE PRESENT
SUCCESS WERE STATUS BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRANTS.
AND THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE
DEPENDS ON IMMIGRANTS THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR ECONOMY.
AND ENSURE THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
CULTURE.
ALL OF US HER OTHER IMMIGRANTS
OURSELVES CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN OR DESCENDED FROM
IMMIGRANTS.
I INTRODUCED THIS RESOLUTION
BEFORE THE EVENTS OF RECENT DAYS
INVOLVING THE SEPARATION OF
CHILDREN FROM THEIR FAMILIES BUT
CERTAINLY.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME OF
HISTORY WHEN IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT EACH OF US ON ALL OF US
STAND UP FOR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
AND WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND HOUSE OF THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR ONE TWELVE AND
JOINED IN CELEBRATING THE RICH
CULTURE IMMIGRANTS HAVE BROUGHT.
TO OUR COUNTRY AND OUR STATE FOR
GENERATIONS CALIFORNIA THOSE.
A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO OUR
IMMIGRANT POPULATION THEY
PROVIDED NECESSARY BACKBONE TO
OUR ECONOMY THEY ENRICH OUR ARTS
TRADITION AND CULTURE AND THEIR
CHILDREN ARE THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE.
I OWE SO MUCH TO MY GRANDMOTHER
HER NAME WAS OLGA WHO IMMIGRATED
HERE TO SEEK A BETTER AND SAFER
LIFE.
MOST OF US OWE A DEBT TO SOMEONE
IN OUR FAMILY TREE YOU CAME TO
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CALIFORNIA FOR A BETTER LIFE.
IMMIGRANTS TODAY COME.
UP FOR A BETTER LIFE.
TO THEY TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD
TO AN UNKNOWN LAND WITHOUT
KNOWLEDGE OF OUR LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE.
IMMIGRANTS OUR COUNTRY'S PRESENT
AND FUTURE AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK THE MEMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO --
FOUR VERY WELL ARTICULATED THE
VALUE OF IMMIGRATION AND
IMMIGRANTS TO OUR COUNTRY I JUST --
ADD A A PERSONAL VERY SPECIFIC --
REMINDER OF THAT AND MY DAUGHTER --
OVER SPRING BREAK WENT WITH HER
CLASS TO ELLIS ISLAND AS PART OF
A TRIP THEY HER ORCHESTRA WAS
TAKING TO A NEW YORK CITY.
AND SHE I CAME BACK AND SHOWED
PICTURES FROM THAT TRIP TO ME
AND ONE OF THE PICTURES WAS OF A
PIECE OF PAPER.
THE PIECE OF PAPER HAD THE NAME
PIETRASANTA BELLY ON IT.
AND IT WAS MY GRANDFATHER HER
GREAT GRANDFATHER WHO CAME
THROUGH ELLIS ISLAND NINETY
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
AND HERE SHE WAS STANDING NINETY
EIGHT YEARS LATER --
LOOKING FOR HIS NAME ON THAT ON
THAT WALL OF HONOR THE TO ELLIS
ISLAND.
AND IT WAS A REMINDER AT A TIME
WHEN ITALIANS WERE CONSIDERED AN
INFESTATION OF OUR COUNTRY.
THEY WERE CONSIDERED SUBHUMAN
AND PERHAPS NOT FROM A COUNTRY
THAT --
OTHERS WANTED IT IN AMERICA
WANTED THEM TO COME HERE.
AND HE CAME HERE AND CAME
DIRECTLY TO CALIFORNIA AS THE
GREAT LAND GOLDEN LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY AND HIS CHILDREN
WERE AWARD WINNING TEACHERS.
DOCTORS PROVIDING GREAT MEDICAL
CARE TO CALIFORNIANS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO WERE DECORATED --
AND ALSO SERVED IN THE ARMED
SERVICES AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO WENT ON TO A PROVIDE
NOT ONLY GOOD SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT HIRE PEOPLE WHOSE
FAMILIES THEN WORKED IN THAT
BUSINESS.
IMMIGRATION IS SO GOOD FOR
AMERICA AND THAT PERSONAL
DEPICTION PROBABLY MOVED ME MORE
THAN ANY OTHER PICTURE SHE
SHOWED ME FROM THAT NEW YORK
TRIP.
AND I I THINK YOU ARE THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE AGAIN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WROTE AND A CELEBRATION OF
IMMIGRANTS IN OUR COUNTRY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER KANSEN CHU
JUREK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER I RISE TO SUPPORT HR ONE
ONE TWO MOMENT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE.
WERE FROM SAN SCHOOL FOR
INTRODUCING THIS --
A RESOLUTION.
AS AS THE MOST RECENT IMMIGRANT
MYSELF I KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK HARDER.
BOTH BODY AND MIND.
AND AND TO ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
EVER SINCE I LANDED IN UNITED
STATES I HAVE BEING ASK.
WELL OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHAT DO AMERICAN GET FOR TAKING
AND IMMIGRANTS?
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON THAT I
DECIDED TO RUN FOR THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
AND THE CITY COUNCIL AND AMBIK
HERE AT THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
I'M VERY VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT
THE VERY VERY DIVERSE COMMUNITY
IN MY DISTRICT.
MORE THAN SEVENTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES ARE SPOKEN AT HOME AND
AT WORK DAILY.
NOW ARE YOU I'M WAS SHUT HOME
FOR HOME.
FOR HOME FOR AN IN HUMAN TO A
RHETORIC M. POLICIES COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON.
I BELIEVE NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO STAND UP FOR OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
AND TO CELEBRATE HOW DALY AND
REACH OUR STATE.
AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
Q. MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR.
ONE TWELVE YOU THINK ABOUT IT
WE'RE ALL IMMIGRANTS EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM.
I WAS THE NATIVE AMERICANS WHOSE
LAND THIS WASN'T SO THAT MAKES
US ALL IMMIGRANTS ARE.
IMMIGRATION EXPERIENCES MIGHT BE
VERY VERY DIFFERENT --
SOME HAVE COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
SOME.
ARE CAME AS AFRICAN SLAVES.
OTHERS CAME THROUGH ELLIS ISLAND
BUT WE ALL HAVE COME --
AS IMMIGRANTS.
AS SOMEONE WHO IDENTIFIES AS AN
AFRO LATINO.
I AM PROUD TO RISE ON BEHALF.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR.
ONE TWELVE MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT.
MY MOTHER EMIGRATED HERE FROM
PANAMA.
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS BORN IN
COLOMBIA MY GRANDFATHER IN
JAMAICA MY FATHER EMIGRATED ALL
THE WAY FROM DETROIT MICHIGAN BY
WAY OF MISSISSIPPI.
THE GRANDPARENTS WHO WERE SLAVES.
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE
SIMPLY BUILT THIS COUNTRY.
WITH THEIR FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH THERE LABOR
WITH THEIR HARD WORK.
AND BY TODAY'S STANDARDS
IMMIGRANTS IN CALIFORNIA.
CONTRIBUTE. TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS 28% OF OUR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME. SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY IF FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION IN TAXES.
ARE IMMIGRANT FAMILIES COME HERE
TO SEEKING A BETTER LIFE IN SIKI
TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
LIKE MY GRANDMOTHER WHO WORKED
CLEANING PEOPLE'S HOUSES MANY
IMMIGRANTS COME HERE JUST WANTED
A CHANCE TO WORK. TO CONTRIBUTE
AND SOMETIMES TAKING JOBS THAT
NO ONE ELSE WOULD WANT.
AND SAMMY WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
PERIOD WHERE IMMIGRANTS HAVE
BEEN TREATED IN A HOSTILE MANNER.
IN CHILDREN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
LET OF SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION
THIS HR HOUSE RESOLUTION.
AND CALL ON CONGRESS TO COME UP
WITH REAL.
AN APPROPRIATE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO BE
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT TO BE PART
OF THIS GREAT NATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR.
ONE TWELVE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY AS YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
LIKE LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD.
WE LIVE IN A NATION WHICH SINCE
ITS BEGINNING HAS BEEN BUILT BY
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT CURRENTLY WE ARE FACED WITH
THE CULMINATION OF LONG STANDING
DISCRIMINATORY IN SOCIAL BE
ABUSIVE POLICIES REGARDING
IMMIGRATION.
AND IN PARTICULAR BY THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE A
HABIT OF IGNORING THE GREAT
HISTORY OF IMMIGRANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN SPITE OF THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WE WERE CELEBRATE AND RECALL THE
RICH HISTORY OF IMMIGRANTS IN
ALL THE WAYS THEY'VE
STRENGTHENED OUR NATION.
BY DOING SO WE ACTIVELY FIGHT
AGAINST THE FALSE NARRATIVES
WHICH SUPPORT BACKWARDS
IMMIGRATION POLICIES AND
IMMIGRATION ORDERS.
AS IT STATES AT THE BASE OF THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY.
GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR
YOUR HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE FAMILIES
ASKING TO SEEK ASYLUM. TO
BREATHE IN THE FREEDOM.
AND INSTEAD WE SEE THEIR
CHILDREN RIPPED AWAY FROM THEM.
HAVE WE NOT LEARNED FROM THE
SHAMEFUL HISTORY OF SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS.
THIS IS NOT THE AMERICA I LOVE.
WITH THE IMAGES OF CHILDREN.
LOCKED UP IN CAGES.
ON UNITED STATES SOIL.
CRYING AND PLEADING TO BE
RETURNED TO THEIR PARENTS.
I FEEL ANGERED AND SADDENED.
BUT TODAY I STAND PROUDLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE HERITAGE OF ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO SIMPLY WANT
ONE THING.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAFELY AND
SECURELY LIVE AND BUILD THEIR
DREAMS.
THEY WANT TO THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WE MUST AND WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT TO MAKE THIS DREAM
POSSIBLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOUR SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS
SAW.
IE.
RISE SO IN SUPPORT OF OUR THEY
SHOT. ONE ONE TWO TO RECOGNIZE
SO JUNE. TWENTY OUR EIGHTEEN AS
OUR IMMIGRANT IMMIGRANT THE
HERITAGE MONTH [inaudible]
WE ARE.
OR ONE FORM OR ANOTHER.
IMMIGRANTS FROM SOMEWHERE. ONE
OF THE MOST OF REASON IMMIGRANT
MYSELF.
FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT.
EXACTLY FIFTY YEARS AGO
[inaudible]
I WHEN OUR SHARE WITH YOU MY
STORY WHEN I ARRIVED.
ARE IN THIS COUNTRY.
WITH A FIFTY DOLLARS IN MY
POCKET.
WHO WOULD OF JEWELRY IN?
THAT I WOULD TO SIR.
MY COMMUNITY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A SCOREBOARD DOT.
MAYOR AND EVENTUALLY YEAH.
ON THIS HOUSE ARE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF REPRESENTING
MY SIXTY EIGHT THE DISTRICT.
THIS SYSTEM CELEBRATION OF ALL
WERE [inaudible]
HERITAGE.
FROM WHEREVER YOU MAY COME FROM.
THIS IS HOW NOT TO CONDEMN.
ANY.
CURRENT SITUATION IS SO WE ARE
ALL HERE TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND THE CELEBRATE THAT AND THE
RESPECT EACH OTHER.
AND I'M I'M SO GREAT FOR THAT
AMERICA.
IS.
PRONE OF ALL THE PARENTAGE.
DIFFERENT CULTURE THAT WE BRING
IN AS A IMMIGRANTS.
AND THE RECOGNIZE SO TODAY
[inaudible]
AS OUR IMMIGRANT HERITAGE MONTH.
MY GUESS R. H. OUT.
ONE ONE TWO I STRONGLY URGE YOU.
YOUR I'VE WORKED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
IF YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR --
ONE TWELVE MYSELF THE SON OF
IMMIGRANTS LIKE MY COLLEAGUE GOV
FROM OAKLAND.
PARENTS FROM PANAMA.
BUT I ALSO RISE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE HISTORY OF AMERICAN
IMMIGRATION HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN
A PROUD HISTORY.
AND ALTHOUGH WE CELEBRATE OUR
SILENT.
I SOMETIMES FORGET [inaudible]
ANGEL ISLAND --
OFF THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
PERMISSION TO RE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
DESTRUCTION OF ANGEL ISLAND
IMMIGRATION STATION BEGAN IN.
NINETEEN OH FIVE BUT WAS NOT
USED UNTIL.
NINETEEN TEN SO THE ZONE WAS
KNOWN AS CHINA CO.
IT WAS BUILT FOR CONTROLLING
CHINESE ENTRY IT TO THE UNITED
STATES.
FROM.
NINETEEN TEN TO NINETEEN FORTY
ANGEL ISLAND SERVED AS AN
IMMIGRATION STATION.
PROCESSING IMMIGRANTS FROM
EIGHTY FOUR DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION BEING
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS.
PURPOSE OF THIS IMMIGRATION
STATION.
WAS TO INVESTIGATE CHINESE WHO
HAD BEEN DIE DENIED ENTRY.
BECAUSE OF THE CHINESE EXCLUSION
ACT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO
IMMIGRANTS HAD TO PROVE THAT
THEY HAD HUSBANDS OR FATHERS.
WHO WERE UNITED STATES CITIZENS
IN ORDER NOT TO BE DEPORTED?
ANGEL ISLAND WAS A HUMILIATING
EXPERIENCE FOR MANY IMMIGRANTS
WE CAN GO THEIR TODAY AND SEE
THE WRITINGS ON THE WALL OF THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO WERE HELD THERE.
UP TO TWO YEARS.
SO AS WE CELEBRATE ELLIS ISLAND
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER ANGEL ISLAND.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION HR ONE TWELVE EIGHT
IT'S HR ONE TWELVE BY MISTER
CHIU.
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WHILE WE CELEBRATE THE
WONDERS OF IMMIGRATION AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT HAS BASICALLY
HELPED TO BUILD THIS NATION.
I HAVE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH ONLY
ONE CONCEPT.
THE ENSLAVED WERE NOT IMMIGRANTS.
IT THE CONCEPT OF IMMIGRATION
IMPLIES THERE'S A DESIRE TO COME.
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING A BETTER
LIFE.
AND THAT THIS COUNTRY HOPEFULLY
WILL WELCOME YOU IN.
THAT IS NOT THE LIFE OF MY
GRANDPARENTS AND MY GREAT
GRANDPARENTS.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION I WANT TO ALWAYS
REMIND FOLKS THAT THERE IS A
POPULATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT HELPED TO BUILD THIS NATION.
SPENT A LOT OF THEIR TIME IN
BLOOD AND ENERGY WORKING ON
BEHALF OF CREATING AN AMERICA.
THAT WERE NOT IMMIGRANTS AND THE
IN SLAVE SHOULD NEVER BE
CLASSIFIED WITH THE IMMIGRANTS
NOT THAT THAT'S A SHAME TO IT
BUT IT'S A SHAME TO US THAT WE
WOULD THAT WE WOULD DISREGARD.
HOW WE GOT HERE THE STRUGGLE
THAT WE'VE HAD AND OUR
CONTINUING EFFORT TO BE SEEN AS
EQUAL WITH EVERYONE ELSE SO I
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION I KNOW
THAT ARE IMMIGRANTS HAVE WORKED
HARD IN THIS COUNTRY?
HAVE HELPED TO BUILD THIS NATION
WOULD NEVER EVER SHOULD WE EVER
SAY THAT THE ENSLAVED WERE
IMMIGRANTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEN'S BIGGER MEMBERS --
GUYS A DESCENDANT OF IMMIGRANTS
TO THIS COUNTRY I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF HR ONE TWELVE AND YOU KNOW
WHEN MY ANCESTOR CHARLES
GALLAGHER CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
IN --
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT NO THIS WAS
THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY FROM
IRELAND HERE WITH A SCAPIN.
A PLACE WHERE HE FACED
OPPRESSION --
HIS SON ANTHONY WAS THE FIRST TO
BE BORN.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES --
SO I'M VERY SENSITIVE --
WHEN WE HEAR XENOPHOBIC AND ANTI
IMMIGRANT [inaudible]
RHETORIC.
BECAUSE MY ANCESTORS FACE NEED A
LAWS NO IRISH NEED APPLY --
MY ANCESTORS WERE OFTEN PUSHED
OUT A COMMUNITIES AS WELL --
AND AND FACED THOSE SAME KIND OF
AT THAT SAME KIND OF ADVERSITY
SO I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO THAT.
AND WE SHOULD CALL THAT OUT WHEN
WE SEE IT.
WE SHOULD CALL OUT INJUSTICE
WHEN WE SEE IT [inaudible]
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OF THIS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS TO USE WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IS A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL.
ON BOTH SIDES.
IS NOT HELPFUL AND DOESN'T HELP
US GET TO WHERE WE ALL KNOW WE
NEED TO GO.
I'M GLAD THAT THE PRESIDENT.
HEARD THE CAUSE OF MANY OF US
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TO
AND FAMILY SEPARATIONS AT THE
BORDER.
YOU WOULD DO HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
YESTERDAY.
THAT IS AN A BORN IN IT'S AN
IMMORAL PRACTICE.
AND PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES HAVE
SAID THAT IT'S ALSO A PRACTICE
IT OCCURRED UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL.
AND WE NEED TO WE NEED TO CALL
OUT THE TRUTH.
IT'S AN ABORT PRACTICE NO MATTER
WHOSE ADMINISTRATION IF FALLS
UNDER.
IT ALSO NEEDS TO BE SAID.
THEY CATCH AND RELEASE IS NOT.
A HUMANE POLICY BECAUSE CATCH
AND RELEASE ACTUALLY ENABLES
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
AND ENABLES DRUG CARTELS. TO DO
WHAT THEY DO TO PEOPLE WHICH IS
A BORN IN A MORAL AS WELL
[inaudible]
WE NEED [inaudible]
A GOOD.
IMMIGRATION AND ASYLUM POLICY IN
THIS COUNTRY AND WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS THAT.
IT'S CONGRESS'S RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT'S SO WE SHOULD ALL ON BOTH
SIDES ALLEN COURAGE OUR
LEGISLATORS ARE CONGRESS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
OUR SENATORS TO GET TO WORK.
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR JOB TO ENSURE
THAT THAT IMMIGRANTS.
CAN COME TO THIS COUNTRY THAT
THOSE SEEKING ASYLUM CAN COME TO
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT HAS DONE SO IN AN
ORDERLY PROCESS ONE THAT
PROTECTS FAMILIES AND PROTECTS
[inaudible]
ALL PEOPLE --
AND SO LET'S LET'S JUST BE REAL
ABOUT.
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE LET'S NOT USE
THAT AS A POLITICAL FOOTBALL ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
LET'S ENCOURAGE GOOD POLICY BE
MADE SO THAT SO THIS COUNTRY
CONTINUE TO BE.
A PLACE OF REFUGE.
AND A PLACE WHERE IMMIGRANTS WHO
COME AND BUILD ON THE GREATNESS
OF THIS COUNTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
SHE WAS ALSO THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
PAUL AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAME CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT ACR TO FORTY EIGHT MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
IF YOU MATTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'MSORRY I BEG YOUR
PARDON MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
THE ITEM.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FORTY EIGHT BY SOME THE
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA RELATIVE
TO PARKS MAKE LIFE BETTER MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ACR.
TO FORTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO LOCAL
PARKS TRAILS OPEN SPACE AND
FACILITIES SUCH AS SWIMMING
POOLS GREAT PARKS [inaudible]
BUT PARKS TENNIS COURTS NATURE
CENTERS AND MUSEUMS FOR THE
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS RESOLUTION DECLARES THE
MONTH OF JULY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS PARKS MAKE LIFE
BETTER MONTH.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
CLOSE WITH SAYING THAT JUST
ABOUT THAT.
TWENTY DAYS AGO OR SO THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA GAVE US A GREEN
LIGHT.
IN APPROVING PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THAT WOULD MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS.
PERHAPS IN A HISTORY OF THE
STATE SOME OF THE LARGEST
INVESTMENTS. TO A POOR PART
COMMUNITIES AT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE THANK
THEM. FOR THE VOTE OF CONFIDENCE
IN NOW OUR JOB TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS BENEFIT.
FROM THOSE INVESTMENTS THAT WITH
THAT NOW COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WOULD OPEN THE FIRST
ROLE FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ MOM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TO FORTY EIGHT ASK SOMEONE WHO'S
PUBLIC SERVICE BEGAN WITH
ADVOCATING FOR THE IMPROVEMENT
OF A PARK IN NYC IN MY COMMUNITY.
I KNOW HOW HOW IMPORTANT PARKING
METER COMMUNITY.
PARKS GIVE FAMILIES AND THEIR
CHILDREN A PLACE TO EXERCISE
PLAY SPORTS WHICH PROMOTE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
I THINK THE AUTHOR FROM HOTEL
OFFERING THIS.
ACR FORWARD ARE ABSTRACT.
RESPECT BROWN'S RIVAL DOES WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MEMBER
BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FOR THIS RESOLUTION ARE MEMBER
TO FROM COACHELLA.
AND I JUST AS A REMINDER THAT SO
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS LIVING
SPEND MOST OF THEIR TIME IN DAYS
IN CONCRETE AND INSIDE AN
INDOORS AND BUILDINGS AND
CERTAINLY PARKS.
OTHER WE DRIVE.
FOR ENJOY YOUR WONDERFUL BUT SO
ARE OUR LOCAL IN A REGIONAL
PARKS WHICH SUPPORTED BY THE
VERY BOND MEASURE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER --
TO PASS AND TO AND PUT BEFORE
THE VOTERS.
AND JUST TO WANT TO SHARE --
A QUOTE THAT I LOVE.
BUT WE ARE CONNECTED TO RATHER
THAN WHAT WE ARE SEPARATED FROM.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MANY BENEFITS
THAT PARKS DO FOR ALL OF US --
AS IT MAKES LIFE BETTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK.
MR GARCIA WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
THE FIRST WILL OPEN HER
COAUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MY PERKY MAY CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
I AM THIRTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY AJ OR FORTY
ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY TRACK RESOLUTION FORTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER THURMOND
TO RELATIVE TO SOCIAL SECURITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN.
THANK MEADOW SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RICE WAS AND AJ ARE --
FORTY ONE THIS A CALLS ON
CONGRESS IN THE PRESIDENT TO
REMOVE OFFSETS THAT REDUCE
SOCIAL SECURITY FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN OUR STATE --
THESE OFFSETS ARE REFERRED TO AS
THE GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET IN
THE WINDFALL ELIMINATION
PROVISION.
WHICH REDUCE SOCIAL SECURITY
PAYMENTS FOR TEACHERS UP PEACE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE IN
OUR STATE --
ESSENTIALLY THERE ARE THOSE WHO --
WHO HAVE SERVED IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WHO BECOME PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES WHO FIND THEMSELVES
EITHER NOT ELIGIBLE FOR SOCIAL
SECURITY OR THEIR SOCIAL
SECURITY SAID MERELY REDUCED --
BECAUSE OF OUR OF THE RULES THAT
SAY IF YOU'RE A PUBLICSECTOR
EMPLOYEE YOU WILL NOT RECEIVE
SOCIAL SECURITY OF THIS
CONTRIBUTES TO OUR INABILITY TO
RECRUIT --
TEACHERS AND POLICE OFFICERS AND
IN MANY WAYS PUTS MANY OF OUR
YOUR EMPLOYEES IN A POSITION OF
INSECURITY WHEN THEY RETIRE ON
BEHALF OF OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES WHO SERVICE WELL.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN ASKING
CONGRESS TO REPEAL THE
GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET IN THE
WINDFALL ELIMINATION PROVISION I
RESPECT WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SUMMER OBERNOLTE ARE
RECOGNIZED META SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AJ R. FORTY ONE
SOCIAL SECURITY IS NOT.
AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM SOCIAL
SECURITY IS SOCIAL INSURANCE AND
LIKE ANY INSURANCE POLICY IF YOU
HAVE PAID THE PREMIUM IF YOU
PAID INTO THE PROGRAM YOU
DESERVE THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM.
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO FURTHER
REQUESTS SPEAK MISTER THURMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A WE ARE
YOU REQUESTING COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION AFFECT MEN SPEAKER I
DO REQUEST OF THE FIRST RULE BE
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MEDICAL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
BUT A CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS THIS DOES REQUIRE A ROLL
CALL VOTE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE WITH
THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN AT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS FORTY ONE THROUGH FIFTY
NINE WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY BY SOME
A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA RELATIVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA CAREER RESOURCE
NETWORK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT I QUICKLY IS OPEN THE ROLE
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
METACRITIC YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY TO NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
METAPHORICALLY THREE THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
THREE WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AND I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
ITEM SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
FORTY AYE SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO
FORTY TWO AYE SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SIMPLE FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
I SEVENTY THREE NO. ZERO AND
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO MOVING NOW TO MR BONTA WHO
HAS A SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS MISTER BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS ONE OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IT'S MY GREAT HONOR. TO
RECOGNIZE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GRADUATING CLASS OF BROOKLINE
MEN'S HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
JUST THIS PAST SPRING I HAD THE
PLEASURE.
OF RECOGNIZING THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION FIVE DOUBLE EIGHT
ACCLIMATIZED WILL FOOTBALL
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM FOR THEIR
ACHIEVEMENT IN SPORTS.
TODAY I'M RECOGNIZING THE CLIMB
AND SENIORS FOR THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
ALL MY KLEIMAN SENIORS GRADUATED
THIS PAST YEAR AND 97% OF THOSE
TWO YEARS WILL BE ATTENDING
COLLEGE.
WITH US TODAY THE GALLERY ARE
TWELVE EXCEPTIONAL MCCLINE MEN'S
SENIORS CONGRADULATIONS MCLAGAN
SENIORS THE CITY OF OAKLAND AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF YOU.
I CAN'T WAIT TO FOLLOW YOUR
CONTINUED SUCCESS LET'S GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
THEIR AMAZING ACHIEVEMENTS THANK
YOU CALLER.
MISTER THURMOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS THE
ASSEMBLY PERSON WHO ALSO
REPRESENTS OAKLAND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR THE
INVITATION IN RECOGNITION OF
ARMOR CLIMB IN SENIORS I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING OF THE
CLAIMANTS HIGH SCHOOL --
DIRECTING A NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES AFTER SCHOOL SERVICES
THAT OF WORK IN THAT COMMUNITY
FOR MANY YEARS AND UP.
WE SHARE IN THE CELEBRATION OF
THESE GREAT STUDENTS CAN WE GIVE
THEM ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THE TO THE GRADUATE SOME TO
CLIMB AS HIGH SCHOOL.
WE WISH THEM CONTINUED SUCCESS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY SECOND KNOW
FLOOR SESSION KNOW CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
AND THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
FORM BECAUSE LIFTED AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
GERMANS IN MY THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS REGRET THE PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A JOURNEY
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
OR GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. FOR FOR A
GERMAN IN MEMORY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER YOUR RECOGNIZE YES MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO IN MEMORY OF PAST TO RICKY
LASSITER.
I'M DELIVERY SADDENED BY THE
RECENT PASSING OF RICKY LASSITER
THE PASTOR OF THE NEW M..
ASSURANCE BAPTIST CHURCH WHO WAS
A OUGHT NOT ONLY A MINISTER BUT
A CONSTITUENT AND A FRIEND.
RICKY WAS BORN ON MARCH
THIRTIETH NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IN
AUGUSTA GEORGIA.
HE LISTENED OF THE MARINES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO AND SERVE
FOR FIVE YEARS HONORABLY.
UPON HIS DISCHARGE HE BEGAN TO
WORK EXTENSIVELY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND EVENTUALLY ESTABLISHED
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
MULTICULTURAL CONTRACTORS GROUP
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND HE
BECAME AN ADVOCATE FOR INCLUSION
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CONSTRUCTION AND CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS.
NOTABLY LASATER WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN ENSURING THE PARTICIPATION OF
THE MULTICULTURAL CONTRACTORS IN
THE BUILDING OF THE CONVENTION
CENTER AND PAT CHO AND THE
AIRPORT EXPANSION LINCOLN HIGH
SCHOOL IN A SAN DIEGO LIBRARY
AND MARKET CREEK PLAZA.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AFTER
ATTENDING THE MILLION MAN MARCH.
RICKY LASSITER TOOK THE CALL TO
BECOME A MINISTER AND HE HELPED
ORGANIZE A BLACK MAN UNITED.
BLACK MEN UNITED SERVE AS A
BRIDGE BETWEEN YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN AND BOYS.
IT WASN'T INTERFAITH EFFORT THAT
FOCUSED ON GANG VIOLENCE AND
THAT WAS RUNNING RAMPANT IN THE
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY. FOR HIS
WORK HE RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS.
IN SAN DIEGO NOT ONLY THE HUMAN
DIGNITY AWARD.
BUT ALSO THE LEADERSHIP AWARD BY
CHANNEL TEN A. B. C..
HE WAS ASKED TO SERVICE PASTOR
OF HIS CHURCH AND EVENTUALLY
BECAME PRAYERFULLY BECAME THE
PASTOR OF NEW ASSURANCE BAPTIST
CHURCH IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP HE BAPTIZED OVER
THREE HUNDRED BELIEVERS AND
COUNT AND STABS COUNTLESS OTHER
MINISTRIES OUTREACH MINISTRIES
TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO.
AND AROUND THE STE COUNTY.
ABBOTT UNTIMELY DEATH HE SERVED
AS OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO'S COMMISSION
ON GANG PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION.
HE WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUNG MAN HAD OPTIONS BEYOND
SIMPLY BEING IN THE STREETS.
AND WORK TO BASICALLY TURN
AROUND YOUNG MEN'S LIVES
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF YOUNG
MEN WHO HAVE BELIEVED IN HIM.
WE FOUGHT A GOOD FIGHT ME FINISH
THE COURSE ANY KEPT THE FAITH AS
A LOVING HUSBAND.
A FATHER A FRIEND A GRANDFATHER
A SON A BROTHER AND A PASTOR OF
THIS CHURCH.
SAN DIEGO MOURNED HIS PASSING
BECAUSE WHEN WE WHEN HE PASSED
AWAY VERY SUDDENLY FROM A HEART
ATTACK.
HE WAS JUST A BASICALLY IN THE
MIDST OF TRYING TO WORK TO
CHANGE SAN DIEGO'S POLICIES ON
GANG INTERVENTION.
AND YEAH TO TRUE PASSION TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY CHILD IN SAN
DIEGO HAD AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUCCESS.
HE IS A GIANT IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND THE IMPACT THAT WE HAD WILL
BE PROFOUND IN THE COUNTY.
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF REVENUE
RICKY LASSITER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES THE DUST
REPRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO ATTORNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER AYE OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE HOUSE AND
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS WILL BE
CONTINUED SEEING IT HERE THERE
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER KALRA MOVES AND MISTER
GLORIA SECONDS OF THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE TWENTY FIFTH AT ONE PM
.
GRAYSON ACR ONE SEVEN TWO ITEM
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY TWO AYE IT'S NOT VOTING